[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es eine richtig coole motiv
torte und die praktisch nicht alleine
sondern ein einsatz hast du etwa gibt
dachte kommst hier nicht rein
ich stelle mich glaube ich auch nicht
zugänglich machen sie nicht gerne
ja und das beste ist ich habe überreden
können für meine beste freundin selma
eine geburtstagstorte thema wird was mir
lieber sie ist zwei stücke ich bin sehr
froh dass die dreistöckige ist und ich
bin schon ganz gespannt
die torte wir jetzt ziemlich cool die
selmer habe ich übrigens zufällig
kennengelernt
letztes jahr sind wir in die türkei
geflogen murat ich und die kids und wir
saßen zufällig auf dem hinflug
hintereinander oder auf dem rückflug
nebeneinander ganz genau und ich hab mir
dann erzählt wenig kennengelernt habe
durch zufall
und dann sagte sie warte mit der billig
geflogen die ist mega
seitdem habe ich angefangen sally zu
folgen
und jetzt weiß die selber gar nicht dass
ich ganz viele mädels eingeladen haben
backen für eine geburtstagstorte für
selma die ist leider nicht dabei die
wird sich nicht schwarz wird sagen warum
war ich nicht dabei allerdings aber wir
hatten ja wir hatten wahnsinnig viel
spaß auch selber 22 dann keine
überraschung
wir können hier nicht nur zutritt für
alle zusammen aber wir machen das noch
mal bestimmt ja oder genau und wir haben
nicht so viel zeit die torte muss ja
nach sylt ihre lieblingsinsel und dort
feiert c
und wir haben deswegen nicht dass er
alle freundinnen eingeladen
wir machen eine sache dort kenne ich
habe alle mädels eingeladen und wir
machen eine sachertorte damit ich noch
zeit habe die irgendwie näher zu bringen
weil eine obstsorte oder ähnlichen genau
da hast du mir abgeraten die würde geht
nicht zwei tage nicht überleben und vor
allem die reise nicht überlegen erleben
das heißt wir machen jetzt dienstag
böden backen und creme verbreiten
mittwoch torte dekorieren und samstag
donnerstag flug nach doha mit 1 0 ich
hab's nie versprochen dass ich ihr
beweisfotos schickte er hoffe also
jemand ich krieg wahrscheinlich die
torte die wir gemeinsam backen nicht
noch mal hin dass heißt das was ich die
seit jahren kommt das muss einfach
passiert das passt aber das kriegen ja
also ihr seht unter wenig zeitdruck mit
vielen frauen in der küche werden wir
jetzt eine torte backen ganze mit viel
liebe wird ja ich bin jetzt schon los
geht es mit der sachertorte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fahren sie wären nur heute zeit deswegen
muss man jetzt arbeitsteilung macht wir
müssen jetzt einmal die torten
glattstreichen gefüllt sind sehr schön
und einmal die deckung was willst du mal
weg okay ich mache die deko ich habe
hier drin schon gesehen du hast eine
schuldige legende dann machst du die
deko und die streiche trotten mit ghanas
dort jetzt hole ich das auf
genauso blüten passte die wird schnell
sieht es muss er heute noch aushärten
und wenn's kleben sollte kannst du
becker strecke nehmen nur wenn ich
brauche das nicht und kommt damit es
gleichmäßig wird nimmst du einfach diese
hölzer ein zentimeter von jetzt einfach
so drüber rollen wundere mich aber das
wird das sind wirklich das sind die
tricks des eingangs nämlich erwähnt hast
der name ich nehme ich selber rolle und
rolle und rolle und den deckel wieder zu
dick und zu binden
jetzt nehmen das mal drunter es klebt
zwar nicht aber so flutscht es ein
bisserl besser
ich geb dir back tipps und da gibt es
mehr stimmt absolut seiner not wandte
ich schaffe es nämlich also ich will
jetzt nicht sagt ich kann nicht
schwimmen
ich kann mich über wasser halten aber
ich kann nur eine bahn schwimmen danach
bin ich kaputt meine ausdauer reicht
nicht das ist nicht die ausdauer ist
nicht neu das ist eine technik die texte
sowie bei mir meine technik hier ja wir
könnten viel schneller sein
wahrscheinlich wenn meine technik
stimmen würde
aha du musst an der technik arbeiten du
bist du nicht unsportlich
das bin ich okay dann ist dann ist es
zeit es aber hier ist echt dass die
technik mich nicht wenn ihr die technik
hast dann dann geht's wir haben nämlich
damals bei ihrem stimm unterricht als
mann ich war nicht oft im
schwimmunterricht weil immer krank und
hatte bauchschmerzen
es war immer war es war halt immer
zufällig dann wenn man schwimmen hatte
und dann haben wir noten gekriegt und
ich habe bei der bahn in der es um die
zeit ging bin ich einfach geschwommen
habe die luft angehalten da möchte ich
einfach schwimmen kann eine bahn die
haben ja dem eine bahn nur gestoppt
kölner fragte mich nicht auf die 8
rincon vertreten
und dann ging es um die technik und da
habe ich dann eben auch separat die
atmung angehalten damit ich einfach mich
auf die arme konzentrieren habt ihr
persönlich blau angelaufen
es war eine fahrt nicht nur eine bahn
geschafft weil die ganze partie
ich hoffe du kannst aber besser schon
als mehr warnt jetzt sagt man mit dem
rad noch unsportlich und murat kann
besser spielen das ist richtig
ach gott ja aber ich will ihr leichter
musste müssen wir ihnen zum training mit
mir eins muss ich sagen also ausdauer
hatte ich nur fünf und technik nur zwei
also war ich auf drei bis vier also habe
ich mich ja gar nicht wenn sie bei mir
zeit konnte ich so hab ich dir
eigentlich erzählt dass jedes jeder
zweite drittklässler in deutschland
nicht tun kann oder nicht sicher schön
kanns echt machen das gibt es noch immer
man glaubt ja immer dass das so jeder
schwimmen lernt und dass das nicht
können aber das ist gar nicht mehr so
dass ich weiß noch bei uns war es damals
so meine eltern und ich kam mir als
gastarbeiter und die sind einfach nicht
schwimmen gegangen
das war einfach ich habe sie eine schule
lernen müssen und wir hatten nur in der
ersten klasse schwimmunterricht und
danach nie wieder
aber schau ist zum beispiel heute so
dass erst ab der dritten klasse das ist
dann schon mal unterricht gibt okay also
erste und zweite ist relativ selten
schulen geben es mag ausnahmen gehen wo
das auch eine erstens roten ist aber
eigentlich erst in der dritten
da hab ich will natürlich gedacht da
muss ich irgendwas machen und deswegen
hast du eine stiftung gegründet und wir
sind echt mega erfolgreich und das ist
auch ein thema was nie aufhört und was
macht dir genau mit der stiftung wir
unterstützen grundschulen also wir
unterstützen gar nicht die kinder das
ist also keine hilfen an die kinder
sondern wir unterstützen grundschulen
dabei dass sie kindern das schon mal
bringen weil man sich vorstellt dass
jeder grundschullehrer mit 30 gb ins
schwimmbad geht er ist ja nicht mein
setup als er sah dass die kinder wenig
lernen oder und das unterstützen wir und
jetzt schon toll mit so helfen kann oder
er das tun kann ja vor allem ist nicht
auch so dass jedes jeder zweite tod des
kindes ist immer als erträge ertrinken
eine ganz große todesursache trolley
gänsehaut ich finde das war schon so was
kann man also eine krankheit finde ich
da kannst du nichts dagegen machen oder
zumindest nicht direkt ja da kann ja
nichts dafür wenn er das bekommst aber
schwimmen soll vor allen dingen ist
einfach wichtig dass man darüber redet
ja aber viele leute schieben so die
verantwortung weg der eltern denken die
schule kümmert sich die schule hatte
überhaupt nicht die möglichkeiten der
sondern manche eltern kriegen keinen
platz irgendwie im schering oder oder
ist auch echt schwierig also sanierer
war im schwimmkurs auf extrem
schwierigen platz zu finden und dann ist
es nur ein mal die woche
dann sagt sie du mal gespielt da erst
mal gar nix bis die damals schwimmen
lernen
also wenn ihr da noch mehr infos haben
wollt schaut einfach auf die homepage
und da könnt ihr euch nämlich franzis
stiftung schon ganz genau ich komme und
das stimmt sich verkehr reicht es ja ich
bin kein hoffnungsloser fall
wir üben auch da könnte man sicher sein
wer mich inhalt in die psyche schleppt
der wirt ins schwimmbad geschleppt okay
dass ich konzentriere mich nur auf 1 und
musste dann alles wieder zusammen oder
versuche ich alles gleich also wir
drucken oder absagen habe es effizient
arbeiten wir das heißt wir denken jetzt
warte mal erst die 10 mm aus die vier
und fünf die brauchen wir dick und den
rest einfach nur dünner okay gut und
haben das einfach draußen
das ist mal ganz vorsichtig somit den
finnischen oder mit pinsel das geht auch
nur das war keine druckstellen machen
und das werden wir jetzt die zahlen
aufleger diese cache toppen lange
brauchen brauchen wir legen sie faust
offene fenster oder bei heißluft bei 20
bis 30 grad im ofen sofort ventilator
ist immer ganz gut einer stunde 23
die haben jetzt da kommen gleich noch
die stäbchen rein und jetzt einfach die
stäbe tauschen fünf millimeter und
weiter oft und dann sparen wir uns
einmal kneten wieso hab ich die stimme
irgendwo gesehen ja genial was dir super
wenn es dann passt nämlich noch der
anker drauf und der kleine an kasse war
und dann gucken wir einfach welchen wir
benutzen
für so eine richtig tolle torte die
modellieren will und machen wenn wie
lange muss sich derzeit eigentlich
entlang als eigentlich so weit haben ist
weil ja weil ich finde man muss ja nicht
von morgens bis abends in der küche
stehen sondern sich so einteilen dass
man die lust nicht verlieren und dann
sollte man sich vornimmt zuerst die
dekore klar genau alles was aushalten
muss genau halten muss ja und dann gucke
ich immer dass ich den teig am vortrag
mache die ghanas zum einstreichen
wir sind so die sachen die er lang
abkühlen müssen oder es kann ja über
nacht kühlen
deswegen haben wir ja mit den mädels
gestern schon gebacken und die kanal
vorbereitet und dann kommt darauf an wie
detailliert man sein würde also ich
könnte stundenlang differieren da könnte
man sich ja da kann man ja nicht
irgendwie so manchmal ist
minimalistischer schöner
ich glaub das glaubt du kannst auch
nächste mal einfach das habe ich jetzt
genauso hätte eintaucht ich habe es aber
auch vergessen zu sagen ich bin schlecht
und was ist da drin ist drin bank
stärken
der reine kartoffelstärke aber gut mit
pinsel und damit wir den anker später
aufhängen können komme habe ich hier so
eine tolle und ich produziertes löcher
in der mitte hüten und dann können was
an die seile dran hängen ja cool perfekt
die daten einfach da drauf
wir dürfen nur später die zahl nicht
falsch auf die torte sitzen ja
eigentlich wollten wir andere zahlen
nehmen schon wieder acht oder 128 jetzt
aber meiner schwester habe ich zum 36
damals 18 und 18 gemacht jetzt mal zwei
einem gewissen alter ja da will man
eigentlich gar nicht mehr wissen
aber wir schreiben es halt immer fett
auf die torte das ist nicht schlimm und
zwar bei den ausstellern da müssen was
nämlich rausschneiden gab nämlich in der
mitte gar nicht dieses stimmt zumindest
hier oben der tod so ein bisserl
andrücken aber nicht raus durch
ausschneiden war gleich weg das ist
nicht schlimm und die perfekt zu mir und
jetzt haben wir hier die stäbe genau
weil die zahlen waren wir ein stechen
genau und kommando das ist einfach oben
bisschen kleber draufmachen dem essbaren
kleber den essbaren kleber bitte von
dann von unten rein einfach so dass er
so ein bisschen halt hat ja ich hab's
auch immer oben
ich habe die schläge spiels lag gekürzt
die russin die im prinzip nur solange
sein wie maximal die torte ist also
perfekt dann bestehen die später schön
man da machen wir zwei am besten weil
die ja nicht so tief rein gehen ja genau
mache ich den vorne oder lieben so
bittel daneben wir wissen ja recht
genau wenn man sie nur drauf stellt und
drauf gibt gefallen so umriss krise so
sind wir sicher genau und so
verschwindet der stab und man sieht
nichts so sehr gut für jetzt sind wir
hier und haben ja was machst du am
liebsten bei der mama in der küche
backen und modellieren da also alle
recht gut
oder ich mag ja wahnsinnig gern
russischen zupfkuchen lecker den liebig
und der kommt nicht mal aus russland ich
habe den mal gemacht und angeschrieben
alle drunter der kombi aus russland wie
heißt der keine ahnung ich glaube es hat
einer irgendwann mal so genannt man weiß
es nicht ich brauche dich so ein modell
ihr ding machen ja genau
perfekt und es lassen wir jetzt alles
trocknen und dann können wir jetzt die
torte glatt streichen
[Musik]
die erste schicht wird auch immer
relativ schnell fest weil er die torte
gut gekühlt ist das heißt ihr könnt auch
dann direkt mit der zweiten schicht
weitermachen und nicht orte
glattstreichen und ich habe jetzt hier
diese garagen boards ich schaue immer ob
die torte gerade ist dann nehme ich mal
jetzt eine wasserwaage eine kuchen war
sie noch ein bisschen ausgleichen
aber ich habe ich jetzt das skateboard
also die garage heraus und ich kann dank
prinzipien außen eine tankkarte ansetzen
und dann diesen schönen rechten winkel
machen
da ist er ist jetzt einfach nur darauf
achten dass die garagen boards
übereinander sitzen und dass sie gerade
sitzen und dann kann ich hier diese
ganzen lücken mit der creme ausgleichen
[Musik]
jetzt bestreite ich hier den rand ganz
großzügig mit der garage und den rest
sich dann mit der zeit gerade schön
glatt ab
[Musik]
jetzt kommt nach dem erneuten kühlen das
feine fisch und zwar habe ich jetzt hier
noch kleine lücken die ich jetzt auch
noch mal fülle und falls die garage x zu
fest geworden ist können diese einfach
immer wieder in der mikrowelle oder über
einen warmen wasserbad ganz vorsichtig
erwärmen so dass wir wieder ein bisschen
streichfähige wird hier beim finish kann
sie ruhig auch ein bisschen flüssiger
sein als streichfähig und dann einfach
ausfüllen und schön glatt sehen
[Musik]
guck mal so wird der rande richtig
schnell richtig schön glatt jetzt
nämlich vorsichtig hier das gern an bord
ab und zwar einfach mit der palette hier
am rand fonds nicht untergehen könnte
auch ein scharfes messer nehmen
wir streichen jetzt noch mal ein
bisschen flüssige ganache drauf das wird
nämlich die unterseite der torte
ich möchte jetzt meiner garage boards
nicht drauf lassen weil er die torte
nach sylt liegt das heißt ich krieg die
garagen wird nie mehr wieder zurück also
nehme ich jetzt hier einen einmal ein
einmal kickboard das lege ich jetzt hier
drauf und klebt ist sozusagen drauf das
wird nämlich jetzt die unterseite der
torte also hier einfach den rahmen schön
glatt machen könnte auch direkte
skateboard alles platzer benutzen aber
die garagen portion immer etwas perfekt
runter
deswegen nehme ich möchte ich ganz gerne
und das skateboard kommt dann am ende
drauf
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt die große dort die
sitzt auch bereits auf einem skateboard
und hier oben lässt sich jetzt das
garagen bord auch ganz einfach ablösen
da habe ich ja keine garage und haus
sondern nur ein bisschen am rand
unternehme ich wir oben drauf immer ganz
gerne
danach stehen noch etwas flüssiger ist
so ein bisschen streichfähige und kann
jetzt auch die oberfläche schön glätten
und die torten dann kühlen befördern die
von land ich drauf kommt
[Musik]
mit immer vorsichtig vom rand zur mitte
streichen
[Musik]
jetzt etwas von dann weiß geknetet
fordernd ist eine zucker über zugs masse
mit der torten gerne eindecken
ihr könnt alternativ auch deko marzipan
nehmen falls es euch besser schmeckt der
von dort bietet sie auf becker stärke
dünn ausgerollt
ich mache immer meinst du drei bis vier
millimeter und das ganze geht am besten
mit etwas becker stärke weil die bäcker
stärke nicht klumpt und man kann sich
später ganz einfach wieder wegwischen
die torten oberfläche ist er jetzt ein
bisschen matsch und auch trocken und
damit erfolg überhaupt darauf haftet
nämlich ein bisschen bakteriums tray und
sprühte ein
wichtig beim von land ist das einfach
die luftbläschen herausgestrichen werden
und ich habe da einen vom band basic
video für euch gemacht wie man trocken
richtig schön klappt bekommt das könnt
ihr euch gerne mal anschauen das sind
wirklich ganz gute tipps und tricks
dabei werden beide trocken mich weiß
eingedeckt
wenn jetzt denkt die ist schon glatt
zeige ich euch ein trick wir sehen noch
größer wird
[Musik]
weiß noch von gongs und dunkle danach
sind wir nicht die besten freunde
deswegen müsste da echt immer gut
aufpassen dass ihr keine schokolade auch
die weiße gar keine schokolade auf den
weißen von dort aber erst jetzt im
prinzip nicht ganz so schlimm denn es
kommt jungs herum aber trotzdem immer
ganz sauber arbeiten können wir jetzt
nämlich noch so ein paar wir heißen die
muscheln muss klarmachen
und zwar so weich zu nehmen
da muss man immer ein bisschen
rumprobieren am anfang ein
und dann muss er die finger mit welcher
stärke und mut machen und dann rein
drücken so genau gewusst wie viel da
rein kommt das zwar perfekt ja da hab
ich nämlich für samira die meerjungfrau
potter gemacht der sicht eines meiner
doch das ist auch das gut hass zurück in
die dann können wir gleich mal blüten
paste ist hier raus nehmen sich bitte
mit meinem sie stellen ja ja ich besuche
der sieht hoffentlich von unten besser
aus als von oben muss hat die ränder weg
machen damit schön wird gleich ob das
kannst du nicht um abschneiden doch mit
leichtem druck
ich glaube ich weiß wäre es weiter macht
kaum samira die selmer frostschutz
kommen so einfacher als muscheln sammeln
dann geschieht das stimmt es geht kommen
wir dass unser mir rates weiter machen
und denken unsere tochter mit von dort
drin
okay die ist nämlich jetzt auch gekühlt
[Musik]
das neue web ein mal hin einmal her
rundherum das ist milch jetzt habe ich
hier das blau und weiß ausgerollt ganz
dünn und nehme jetzt hier wächst hier
ihr könnt dabei auf backpapier nehmen
und einmal um die orte herum lägen
leicht über stehen lassen und
wegschneiden die höhe der torte sind
beim mit knapp 16,5
das heißt das mache ich mir jetzt hier
auf dem papier streifen
ich gebe jetzt einfach noch 5 mm puffer
dazu also 17 dann wegschneiden
das frühere vak trends petrow als
haftmittel eigentlich benutzt man sie da
wird es nicht haftet aber jetzt bricht
so vermittelt bisschen verteilen
so und jetzt machen wir die streifen für
die untere etage und wir haben uns
gerade abgesprochen und wir finden 4 cm
ist eine gute breite finde ich auch
deswegen und jetzt nehmen wir einfach
riesig schon verraten schneiden das hier
sauber ab geht es ein bisschen schneller
rum einen führerschein ein fahrgerät
ohne führerschein
ok und fahrrad okay ist ein fahrer mit
mir deswegen gucken jetzt kann man
entweder direkt an die torte kleben oder
wir machen das jetzt mit diesem papier
und zwar kannst du mir helfen
das ist ja oben alles schön gerade
dieses ressort wir das jetzt machen um
so besser ist es später aus perfekt
ich bin schon schneller als du
hast du schon mal von hand gearbeitet ja
habe ich
und ich bin total begeistert von deiner
von der rolle
dass man es auf rollen kann wie jedes
mal einen abgebrochen habe und dieses
zeug auszurollen und ich war schon sehr
erfinderisch mit flaschen und mit allem
was ich so gefunden habe
und das ist natürlich eine
präzisionsarbeit hier dass die alle so
gleichmäßig dass das social maschine
geht auch roth stimmt deshalb aber noch
nicht probiert mit einer nudelmaschine
auf die idee bin ja nicht gekommen
das klappt super aber man muss geübt
sein so ein bisschen davon nicht leben
für und jetzt jetzt die bäcker stärke so
ein bisschen weg staube das ist wenn die
dran bleibt wenn dazu führen dass wir
jetzt die clips seite und dann lebt
nicht gar nicht so gut und es kann sein
dass so hubl entstehen so klebt das
jetzt ganz von alleine
da nehmen wir jetzt erstmal an kleber
diesmal gerade weg genau wie kriegen wir
jetzt den richtigen maß hast du das
papier ist das papier ausgemacht okay
das viereck gott kann ich das geworden
ja lieber ein bisschen mehr lassen
aber ich habe schon ein bisschen
überstehen lassen das papier nach was
gewusst wer kommt das gedacht dass man
lieber ein bisschen verstehen war weiß
okay
es wird klappen da hat man halt im
prinzip um einen versuch in etappen
verfolgt oder eben nicht
muss man das immer am besten zu zweit
machen oder ist das besser man macht
alleine
du machst ist wahrscheinlich besser
alleine und für leute die nicht die
ersten die user hier merken der hilft
genau so wir machen jetzt mal zu zweit
kleber kein aber noch nie gesehen hab
noch nie was aber klar bei mir fällt
auch öfter mal was ab nein ich hab ja
kommen zum beispiel energie einfach so
drauf
und dann gelingt schön verteilt ganze
ding irgend so ein bisschen das war
praktisch das alles schön einander
haftet hätte waren weiter schon
angebrochen so der ist mal leer
der klebt jetzt ist man ihn weg ist
genau der klebt also ich finde jetzt
schon das wird schon jetzt eine dicke
zuckerschicht die schicht müsst ihr
nicht mitessen aber es ist sehr
dekorativ aus und daher die torte jetzt
ein paar tage halten muss habe ich
deswegen haben wir diese von land decken
unter sonst hätte ich auch direkt
einfach dass da dran mit gibt aber sie
soll ja schön saftig bleiben aber das
ist dann im prinzip ein trick also leyen
an der sache toll gemacht und man macht
sie am anfang der woche und will sie am
wochenende verdanken ist der trick schön
einpacken jaha sorge die immer besser
brand ich wollte ich mir unsere mühe
gegeben
ja wir kriegen das hin wir schaffen das
ist uns jetzt gemeinsam mit mir nach
vorne weiter
wichtig ist das was unten bündig
ansetzende am torten dingsda am kotten
drehte mich lässt dir jetzt hier schön
in der sync in der luft hängen
wir schaffen das
gut wir sind vielleicht an den ein oder
anderen schon wenn ich ganz so hier sind
wir ganz bündig ein bisschen verrutscht
da geht man aber jetzt auch nicht mit
einem persönlich mit einem was kann man
annehmen könnte man dann eben noch mal
ein messer und ganz spitze der justiz
noch mal so und worüber netto stx
praktisch die blase auf und streiks
klappt also man könnte eigentlich auch
ein kleineres kann sie das unternehmen
sind nun nicht an so viel aus
mit was kann man inzwischen mit einer
normalen mit normalen zebari ja doch
noch mitglied begrüßen küchentuch hinweg
nehmen da sollte man auch in werken und
basteln sollte man doch eine gute note
haben wenn man seine torten macht echt
witzige geschichte ich hatte ja bk
leistungskurse kunst und ich habe damals
für die abschlussprüfung im op habe ich
so eine spongebob schwammkopf
unterwasserwelt gemacht modelliert es
richtig aufwendig und detailliert oder
sagt mir eine kunstlehrerin das ist eine
3 damit komme ich in leber und ich
möchte und die kunstlehrerin noch mal
getroffen danach ja und ich habe gesagt
kann man denn so was eigentlich schnell
lernen also meine bei dir sieht das ja
immer so einfach aus und es gibt ja auch
im fernsehen gibt es ja auch so ganz
viele gibt es ja neuerdings so ganz
viele bugs sendungen oder so gerade
prominente in null komma nichts so ein
riesending modellieren es geht so was
schon coole tipps und tricks aber ein
bisschen zwar schon die kreativität
haben finde ich es gibt sachen die sind
nur technisch die kann man mit
schablonen und technik so was wir jetzt
machen und dann gibt sachen die sind
kreativ und da geht es ja darum
irgendwie modellieren oder malen und das
kann man nur wenn man kreativ ist für
das sei nämlich jetzt blau hellblau und
weiß und ich möchte das ganze jetzt so
dass ich einen ambri effekt auf der thor
da ich habe ziehe jeweils 250 gramm und
formen dieser jetzt zu langen strengen
und zwar immer zu so einem kegel der an
der einen seite etwas dicker ist und an
der anderen seite dünner und pre heißt
dass ich einen schönen farbverlauf habe
das heißt unten dunkel und oben hält und
es läuft dann so richtig schön
ineinander
[Musik]
und nur den mittleren farbton also das
hellblau mache ich jetzt gleichmäßig
dick und ich bekomme jetzt den
farbverlauf hin indem ich das weiß
umdrehe das seht ihr jetzt hier schon
jetzt habe ich hier die dunklere decke
und hier gehts dann heller zu damit ich
im prinzip oben mit weiß anfange und
unten mit dunkelblauer aufhöre ziehe ich
das jetzt hier so da ist hier praktisch
dunkelblau geht und über ihnen das
hellblau und dann ins weiß dass nämlich
ein marzipan messer auf der silicon
mathe immer nie mit einem scharfen
messer schneiden und jetzt schneide ich
hier einmal bei 30 zentimetern 41 sind
beteiligt gedrittelt und ihr vorne
schneide ich dann noch da weg wo
praktisches hellblau sich mit dem
dunkelblau vermischt und hier weiß somit
habe ich jetzt hier den ersten farbton
also weiß dann ist hier der zweite
farbton der dritte und der täter die
farben schön vermischen also habe ich
jetzt vier farbabstufungen zumindest in
der theorie in der praxis werden auf
mich selbst aber trocken
[Musik]
ich finde die farbabstufungen hier
eigentlich schon relativ gut
ihr könnt sie aber gerne noch etwas
weicher machen indem er noch
zwischentöne macht die farbabstufungen
von hier nach hier finde ich perfekt
hier und hier und von den ersten beiden
fehlt mir noch ein bisschen also nehme
ich davon ein drittel hiervon etwas und
dann habe ich noch einen zwischen thron
also zumal wir diese kordeln und man
kann sie natürlich einmal so manuell
machen einfach gleichmäßig ausrollen
doch wo ich mit das werden viele kordel
ich dachte ich kann mich mal zum leben
es hat schon schwierig die jetzt
gleichmäßig dick zu machen
ja bei mir sind die irgendwie so kunze
aus die muss man manuell machen weil es
gibt ja oder gibt es irgendwas nicht du
hast nicht was in deiner zauberkiste
womit man einfach wenn du willst mach
ich es mit meiner mutter lea presse und
du kannst du jetzt am meer aus solange
die muschel machen ja bitte aber wenn
man es nicht hat dann geht das so indem
man die dann eben so nimmt und
umeinander zwirbelt und hier dünner die
sind und je mehr man zwirbelt umso
gleichmäßiger aber ok kommen ihr macht
die muscheln und ich mache hier
das ist mir immer schön
[Musik]
ich mache ist die kordeln doch auf die
obere auf die kleinere torte und dafür
nehme ich jetzt hier diese modelle
presse
da kommt jetzt der dunkelste farbton
rein also das dunkelblau
hier vorne habe ich jetzt diesen aufsatz
drauf und jetzt kann ich einfach die
kordel heraustreten
alternativ könnt ihr einfach einzelne
strenge formen diese dann verzweifeln
und dabei die torte kleben
und beim zwirbeln merke ich mir einfach
die drehrichtung dh die rechte hand
dreht nach vorne und die linke hand zu
mir und dann habt ihr alle stränge
gleich
und ich kann jetzt sogar aus messen wie
viele streng ich machen muss ich habe
nämlich eine torte die ist 17 cm hoch
die drei blauen strenge sind jetzt
ungefähr knapp drei zentimeter bereit dh
bei sieben farben komme ich auf ungefähr
17 18 vielleicht jetzt nämlich ein
bisschen s-bahn kleber streiche jetzt
hier auf die torte erst einmal nur unten
ein bisschen verteilen
[Musik]
und die übrigen kommen jetzt hier außen
herum
ich schau jetzt auch immer dass die
strenge hinten abschließen
ich gebe jetzt die kordeln an die torte
und zwar so dass keine naht entsteht das
heißt eine kordel kommt um herum und die
anderen klebe ich dann oben drüber immer
ein bisschen versetzt und dann habe ich
wirklich die torte rundherum richtig
schön
die torte jetzt auf ich finde sie
richtig schön
die kommt jetzt in den kühlschrank und
jetzt wird die untere torte noch
dekoriert dazu knete ich jetzt ein
bisschen blauen von dort und da nehme
ich jetzt das dunkelblau von hier unten
so dass die zahlen getrocknet und
sammelte ich hier auch so ein torten
damit gesteckt aber es geht natürlich
auch einfach vom styropor blog irgendwo
rein das imperial und das sind nicht
auffliegen zum trocknen genau oder man
legt sie eben besprüht erst die
rückseite und dann die vorderseite nach
dem trockenen
möchtest du natürlich muss man aufpassen
dass wir nicht im traum in die kamera
sprechen und so ein bisschen abstand
genau geht ruhig geblieben
so war ich nur oder oder nie seiten
autos eine highlight noch die eigentlich
alle erfahren dass er mit abstritten das
nicht so diese nasen entstehen ja also
das ist beim trocknen und die flasche
immer so halten sonst irgendwann sogar
verliert und dann ich kann es ja auch
eigentlich somit oder dass sich einfach
trauen aber von unten sieht man
irgendwie perfekt
jakobus und aber man sieht schon wie es
an trocknet als 15 minuten achtmal auf
meiner seite
aber deswegen wird er bei mama immer so
schön ist
und die andere die angaben die machen
wir auch in die machen auch goldene
da machen wir auch erst die rückseite
kurz trocknen und dann das ist ja cool
[Musik]
und das wenn man sich selber besprüht
geht das aber gut raus ja es geht
natürlich alles essbare und die mache
jetzt ihren mörder
da warten wir bis trocknet man drehen
was rum und besprühte nochmal so
komplett dessen wird es das da drin dass
man weiß nie das machen wir auch
[Musik]
sambia wird auch immer lidschatten hier
ramadam madame darf ich zum tanz bitten
und ein bisschen browser
aber ich hab' ich hab es wahrscheinlich
jetzt auch überall hängen oder wenn du
jetzt im sommer fahrsaison gold schimmer
business goldzahn so und jetzt malen wir
den namen und die herzliche aufnahme und
damit einfach pulver farbe genommen
die kann man entweder mit back trend
spray vermischen mit wasser oder mit
alkohol und stand einfach schön einmal
und muss man eigentlich aufpassen dass
ich mich ja immer frage bei so kreativen
leuten ist man sieht ja auch unheimlich
viel und du musst aufpassen dass noch
nicht irgendwas kopiert ist ja und
manchmal denkt man das ist eine eigene
idee und dann gibt es aber schon es ist
das schon gibt ja ich glaube jeder hat
ja so seine eigene handschrift
nur ich habe jetzt auch bisher geguckt
nach sylt orte und so maritim und keine
ahnung und aber dann gedanken gemacht
wir machen wir das jetzt nicht zeichnen
sind immer auf murat schaut sich dann an
und sagt okay zum haus das gefällt mir
und das hat sich so dass wir doch aber
auch mal ne schöne die deine ganzen
zeichnung die würde ich ja auch gerne
mal so diese ganzen buch mit nur so
zeichnungen mit so ideen ich habe
tatsächlich mal angefangen zu sammeln
und dann habe ich sie wieder weiß auch
nicht glaube ich muss mal gucken was man
das ist hätte also das finde ich total
spannend ich finde es eigentlich ganz
schön wenn man sieht dass ist so mit
pinsel gemalt ist ja finde ich auch gut
so handmade diese streifen die dann so
drin sind
wir haben nur ein problem
du wirst über gepäck haben ich wäre es
doch schwer müssen die koffer daheim
bleibt ja nachher ich brauche es eine
stunde bis ich zu hause bin ich war
nachher 20 wahrscheinlich selbst
schritttempo
hinter ihr steht ich werde euch anrufen
wenn ich sechs stau wegen franz genau
wenn ich von der polizei abgeholt werden
muss den jungen belästigungen auf der
autobahn also die obere trotter wiegt ja
schon ziemlich viel deswegen müssen wir
jetzt die untere stabilisieren damit die
torte die untere nicht ein drückt nur
kühe sowie im haus praktisch vor stelzen
einbauen und die habe ich jetzt schon
zugeschnitten habe ich immer zu hause
weil ich eben viele torten backen
guck mal kannst du auch gerne wichtig
ist nur also wir machen jetzt so
praktisch so vor dem 2 aber das ist
wieder so ein typischer trick dass ich
mich natürlich immer als laie wunderer
ja wie die dass man eine torte war ich
so nach meinen pferden nach der
fertigstellung aussieht wie so richtig
schön die verabschiedet sich das heißt
ich muss aber auch beim erscheinen muss
ich aufpassen dass ich so genau
also im prinzip ist man ja sowieso dass
er jetzt zwei gleiche torten erst die
obere und die untere weil er unter der
oberen dieser platte runter ist und da
können die platte wegnehmen oder die
sind man ja genau dann okay wenn sie
hier sind jetzt darauf setzen wir
entscheiden mal welche seite ist da die
vorderseite du machst das doch lohnt
immer alleine oder ich also jetzt wenn
so viel arbeit drin steckt dann denke
ich immer das ist der knaller wenn da
was passiert aber es darf man gar nicht
denken oder in e man darf eine
integrierte und wiesen
ich glaube hier wo es ein bisschen
schief war ist hinten wo ist eine
reflexion ein gott also zum transport
nimmst du sie wieder runter
genau deswegen kleben was er jetzt nicht
an und vor ort machst du einfach
bissiger nach strom da kannst du die
tortenplatte festhalten
das thema ethik
also ich finde unten sieht sie jetzt
auch nicht schlecht aus wir können
natürlich wenn wir wollen das macht dran
setzen muss aber gar nicht ist vorne
irgendwo noch eine lücke
blau felder was ja das ist hier ist ja
die hier vorne was man hier also setzt
was doch oder mit sitz in einer zelle
torte aus ne das ist selber sind wieder
so diese kleinigkeiten zu sorgen oder
popup weckt damit aber nicht reagiert
heißt sorgt natürlich für nun auszahlen
die mama zum schluss jetzt müssen wir
eigentlich nur noch entscheiden hatte
dann müssen es nur kurz zu uns drehen
oder den namen unten dran also könnte
hier und das selber auch hier schreiben
das konnten die kordel hier ist der name
hier ist die zu hören
[Musik]
habe ich erlebt dass sich dem drängen
lassen
nein mein gott ich bin so ein lediger
fan doch wirklich noch weg wollte ja das
bin ich nicht
aber lady gaga ist so genial ist mein
gott ich liebe dieses liegt die auch die
so verrückt ich gehe vier tage noch was
wir in ihrem konzern gehört und das neue
lied cello hast du den film gesehen star
is born gehen ja viel spaß bei tue ich
habe den film tatsächlich wegen ihr
geschaut und ich wegen bradley ja ich
war gut gemeint ist eine gute stimme
stimme
das sieht sogar als alkoholiker oder gut
aus du auch kennst du eine gut gehende
umgebung nicht kein wie ich meine wir
gründen eine auf das wird ja langsam
echt unheimlich und ich kann aber nicht
lediger damit singen das kann ich nicht
ohmann naja für die spice girls reicht
ja wenn wir jetzt ein bisschen gekitzelt
aber ich finde das ergebnis ist mega
geworden die mädels haben es ja auch
noch nicht gesehen die von einer ständig
zu flippen aus
ich hoffe sie schmeckt vielen vielen
bestimmt so schön
ach mensch du uns kann man auch zusammen
also ich komme ja tiere weit ihr nochmal
können da oben noch so püschel
drauflegen wenn wir lust haben wenn ich
das nur so weg also meine arbeit ist
hier getan übrigen du sie jetzt
heidemarie sind keine müssen und ich es
nicht mehr in meiner verantwortung und
lasst euch und lasst euch teilen darum
perfekt ist oder nicht sehr gut da
vielen vielen dank
und er findet das rezept auch sally
blog.de schreibt gerne einen kommentar
ihr euch das video gefallen hat ich
fand's mega cool und vor allem cool mit
dir zu backen bist echt back
talentierter geschehen ich komme wieder
wenn ich das gerne sehr gerne
[Musik]